trump is still bragging about the  dementia test he's still talking about  it  do you believe he's struggling  cognitively because that question was  raised about you and i've been around  you long enough to know that that that's  not a problem for you at all  well i went and took a test and as uh  dr ronnie jackson is great great guy now  he's a congressman and they love him in  texas but he said he aced it and i don't  think he ever saw anyone ace it and i i  immediately said because they started  passing the false narrative  guys he's still bragging about the  dimensions as he thinks it's an iq test  he thinks that doing well on a test  meant to screen out relatively serious  dementia that he's worthy of mensa  membership or so i mean it it's 2022 and  he's still doing it